my dad sold suits and my mom was a
stay-at-home mom my mother told me like
you can't ever you shouldn't be a pro
skateboarder you got to go to college
you can't squish look
i'm worth hundreds of millions of
dollars okay my mother said to me three
days ago she listened to a podcast where
i said that i quit high school
and she's like you i don't know why you
keep saying that everyone's gonna think
you're a loser
you're gonna think you're a loser skater
and i'm like that ship has sailed you
know what i mean like it's not they're
not they're more like man he didn't even
finish high school and look at all that
he's doing they're not like concerned
she's still in her mind
is like embarrassed that she let me
leave high school at 16 years old even
with all the success all of the 30 years
later you know you regret that now i
mean no you're not encouraging me he's
got hundreds of millions of dollars he
just told you how happy he is but
you're not endorsing people not finish
high school yeah look i i'm endorsing i
think that he's endorsing people living
the dream that he is living
if you have a passion for something and
it's not about quitting see it's not
about quitting he didn't quit he moved
on to something else it's not like i
just that's the negative i don't wanna i
don't wanna go to school okay you don't
wanna go what do you wanna do you can't
just say i don't wanna go to school yeah
and it wasn't that i had turned became a
professional skateboarder at 16 and went
to europe for the world championships
and got fourth and like
the world championships well also keep
in mind in that year i did
uh make uh for the year 842 dollars
and i sold one signature board in
december of 1991 so my salary for that
month was two dollars
you know so a pro skateboarder in 1991
was not nearly as we were talkative as
it is today uh jackie and i were talking
yesterday and jackie was a teacher for
10 years and taught in elementary school
and i said that our education system is
[ __ ] because big time
there's no um i think it's a way i think
life is too short and i think to spend
18 or 20 years in school i'll just say
it in our system that we have now is a
waste of [ __ ] time because once you
learn to read and once you learn to
write
and once you learn to uh add and
subtract
that gives you the tools to make a
decision
about what you're passionate about you
know that that's they're not teaching
you anything or they're not giving you
the information like when you're
learning calculus you go what the [ __ ]
do i do with this or you're learning
something about history you go how do i
if you're passionate about history and
you want to learn that
i think we should be able to make the
choices
earlier than they allow you to like they
don't teach anybody economy yeah and
look i i think there's all that
fundamental stuff that you get no
fundamental skills when you pop out of
there but but the beauty of school is is
it's systematic evolution right like you
actually are living inside this
beautiful framework where you get to
grow year over year and evolve inside a
system right so the way that school is
set up
it's actually this beautiful framework
for you to evolve inside and grow and
learn it's just what's taught inside
that system
is is
antiquated for the time right it was
back then it was really just get a nice
general knowledge base you're just
learning to be structured and and go
through testing systems that basically
got you ready for the work the workforce
right and as we've evolved into being
able to up what opportunity presents
itself at this day and age is so
different that what school that same
system needs to actually teach you life
skills right and it's like you know i
you know i gotta you know go through the
process of putting my children in
private schools right now i got to go
through had to write a whole thing this
morning about uh you know my my
application for my kids and had to write
all this story you know and all this but
when i went and toured these schools
they have the difference between a
growth mindset and a fixed mindset in
kindergarten and to me like just that
mentality to my my five-year-old of like
here's the difference of always growing
and evolving versus being fixed because
i grew up in a fixed mindset household
went to a fixed mindset school raised by
fixed mindset parents around fixed
mindset family that all told me
everything that i ever wanted to do was
impossible and if i wanted to achieve
i'd have to go to college to get a
little bit better job than getting a job
right out of high school
[Music]
you